hello everyone welcome to another tango
technique class at home i hope you are
all doing fine
today's class will be for men and women
together and if you're a woman i
recommend you that today you use your
tango shoes yeah do it on your high
heels because it will be good today we
will use the metal room because we need
a steady time reference to adjust the
speed of our movements and make them all
equal yeah and we will also use the
stick but today we can use it in a
different way than the way that we have
been using it in the last videos okay
so today we will start improving our
walk our tango walk yeah in all
directions front side and back and we
will do that by using projection yeah in
download we call projection
when you start a step by moving your
free foot through the floor in the
direction that you want to go and that
is the first movement that you do when
you step yeah projection
you project the leg or you project the
foot into the step yeah that's what it
means
and projection is one of the two
basic techniques that they are to walk
yeah the other would be a pendulum but
we will see that in another video
so today after the warm-up we will do
three
blocks of exercises in each block we
will concentrate in projecting in one
direction yeah front side or back
and then in each block we will have
different exercises for the same
direction in which we will combine
projection with
flexing and stretching our standing leg
different speeds slow and fast and also
the association of the doors to make the
exercise more complete okay
so i hope you will like the class and
let's start with the warm up okay warm
up so let's start with feet together
straight posture
look front
and relax the arms and we start with
shoulder rotations yeah remember not to
bend the elbows when you rotate the
shoulders okay let's do eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight okay now we do arm circles
yeah remember to keep the elbows
straight all the time and to pass the
hands behind your back so that you
stretch the chest muscles as well okay
let's do eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
okay
now we stretch the side of our torso now
we raise an arm with the elbow straight
and then we slide the handle is down
down our leg until you can touch the
side of your knee you hold this stretch
for three seconds and then you come back
up and you drop the arm okay and then
we'll repeat to the other side so let's
do it four times to each side let's go
one
go down hold it
and go up
and one
pull down
hold the
stretch and go up
two
go down
hold it
go up
two
go down touch the knee
hold it
and go up
three
go down
hold the stretch
go up
three
go down
hold the stretch
go up
four
go down
hold the stretch
go up
and four
go down
hold the stretch
and go up
okay now open the legs a bit wider than
your shoulders and bend the knees a
little bit yeah then keep your hip
straight and look in front during the
whole exercise and also your head okay
make a circle with your arms in front of
you keep your hands
uh below the chest
and then rotate your torso left and
right making sure that you move the
torso with the arms together and not the
arms along okay you want to work with
your back yeah torsion in the torso
let's do it 16 times so twice eight
times okay let's go
one
[Music]
two
three
five four nine five
six and seven and eight eight more
one and two and three and
four and
five and six and seven and
eight okay make sure that you are not
rotating the hip on this exercise okay
so now you stretch the legs
knees are straight and then you put your
hands behind your head if you want your
back to work more or you put your hands
on your hips if you want your back
to work not so much okay so i will do it
with my hands behind the head
and then you bend down from the hip
keeping your back straight until your
back is parallel with the floor and then
from here you continue going down using
the weight of your head you relax here
and you bounce three times one two three
for a light stretch behind your legs
and then you go up again slowly okay
so let's do it eight times
one go down
[Music]
then
bounce bounce bounce
and go up
two
go down
bounce bounce bounce
go up
three down
bounce back bounce
what four
go down
bounce bounce bounce
up
five go down
bounce bounce bounce very relaxed
and go up
six go down
bounce bounce bounce
and go up
seven
and go down bounce bounce bounce go up
and the last one eight
go down bounce bounce bounce
and go up okay
now
you put your hands on your hips and you
keep your legs straight and then we do
circles with our hip so you start by
going back with the hip and then you
move your hip to the side yeah keep your
head where it is don't move the head
move the hip and keep your legs straight
then you continue moving the hip forward
and then to the other side and then back
and you make a wide circle yeah
we do it eight times in one direction
and then eight times in the other
direction so let's go go back
and one
two
make it big
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight until you're back and then
change direction
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and
eight
okay
great now
join your legs
make sure that your feet are together
parallel and touching each other yeah
the whole inside of the foot is touching
the other
inside of the foot
and you can keep your hands in your
on your hips if you want then you bend
your knees you bounce three times one
two three then you stretch the knees you
go a little bit forward with your weight
and then you use your ankle and calf
muscles to go up on your toes on the
ball of the foot
uh make sure that your legs are not
opening like this yeah keep them
together together and then you hold this
stretch for three
um three seconds yeah make sure your
core is tight and then you go down
slowly okay
so let's do it eight times one
bounce bounce bounce
go up
stair
and down
two
bounce pass palms
go up
hold this position
go down
three bounce bounce palms
go up
and go down
four bounce bounce bounce
go up
and go down
five bounce bounce bounce
go up
and go down
six
bounce bounce bounce
go up
and go down seven down spans bounce
and go down and eight bounce balance
bounce
go up hold it
and go down slowly okay
last exercise stretch for the calf
muscles
so start with feet together
and move one foot behind you
yeah make sure it's really behind yeah
the distance of a big step
and then
keep your heel on the back foot on the
floor and the legs straight and then
bend the front knee until you feel the
back leg stretching yeah
make sure that your heel is on the floor
yeah don't lift it and then let's count
25 seconds
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
five yeah and then stretch the front
knee slowly to get out of the of this
stretch yeah if the balance is uh
difficult for you here you can hold the
wall yeah just with the fingers don't
lean on the wall yeah but if you can do
it without any help because it will help
your balance a lot okay so let's do the
other side feet together
if you want
uh hands on the hips or hold the ball if
you if you have problems with balance
and then move the other foot behind you
yeah the distance of a big step make
sure the heel is on the floor the leg is
straight and then bend the front knee
until you feel the stretch here yeah
especially on the calf muscles
relax the leg but keep it straight and
let's count 25
5 six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
five six
seven
eight
nine
ten
one
two
three
four
and five and now stretch the front leg
so you get out of the stretch
slowly okay so we are ready let's go for
the first exercise okay in the first
exercise we will use projection of the
free leg to the side okay always to the
side now you have two possibilities with
the stick yeah one possibility is just
to hold it above your head like we have
been doing in the previous videos
remember raising your rib cage and
engaging your back muscles so that the
arms can relax that's the proper way to
hold the stick like this yeah
if you opt for this option you will work
a lot the muscles of your torso the
muscles that you need for a good
straight posture yeah
but if you prefer you can also hold the
stick horizontal
and put your arms in tango and raise
position yeah if you opt for this option
then you focus more on keeping the frame
of your embrace constant through the
exercise you focus more on the position
of the arms and this is also good yeah
now how to do this properly if you're a
man
you start by putting the stick above
your elbows yeah like this the stick
goes flat above your elbows then you
bend the right arm so that the hand
is in the center of your torso yeah and
you bend the left arm so that the fist
goes up
and the palm of your hand is looking
towards your face okay like this if
you're a woman you start with the same
position stick
over your elbows but then you do the
opposite you bend the left arm
so that the hand is in the center of
your torso maybe a bit more up if you
want and then you bend the right arm so
that the hand is going up yeah
and the palm of your hand is looking
away from you yeah if you want you can
close the fingers or keep them open it's
up to you yeah so
man embrace
woman embrace yeah you do what you need
to do so today i will use the stick like
this because i want to focus on my arms
okay
good so the exercise goes like this
you start with your feet together you
find your balance on one leg whichever
you prefer i will show you now the
exercise from the front but then when we
click together i will do it from with my
back to you so you can follow me with
the same leg okay so you find your
balance and then you do two movements at
the same time you open the free leg to
the side keeping the foot on the floor
and making contact with the big toe on
the floor yeah and at the same time you
bend the standing leg so that you go
down like this yeah
and then
you close the free leg in zero position
and you stretch the standing leg yeah so
you open the leg you go down you close
the leg you go up that's it yeah very
simple
now how
fast do we do this or how slow well we
will use a metronome yeah so that we
have a clear
time reference
and we will use
two beats to open the leg and go down
and two beats
to close the leg and go up so it would
be like
fun
okay
now there is one thing you have to be
careful try to avoid stops in your
movement yeah don't do this
pump
you have to adjust the speed of your
movements so that both legs are moving
all the time so do it slowly
so that the legs are moving all the time
[Music]
okay
so we will do it together 16 times with
each leg first one leg sixteen times
then change weight the other leg sixteen
times yeah so twice eight okay let's do
it together
with a metronome
so now i'll do it
with my back to you so you can follow me
with the same leg now put your weight on
the left leg the right leg is free okay
and let's
work on projection to the side
16 times
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
hey
anymore one
two
keep your leg always moving
three
always moving
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay change weight and we live 16 times
now with the weight on our right leg and
the three legs on the left okay let's go
one
two
three don't forget the arms on the torso
four
five
six
seven
eight
eight more
one
keep the leg always moving
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
great
let's go to the next one okay in this
exercise we will do the same but we will
add dissociation yeah so every time you
project your free leg to the side you
will turn the torso away from the free
leg or
towards the free head yeah so one time
you turn the torso towards your standing
leg the next time you turn the torso
towards your free leg okay
now two things about uh torsion first of
all remember the right way to turn the
torso try to make the rotation as low as
you can don't rotate just the shoulders
or the chest yeah try to make the
rotation happen really deep in your
torso right above the hip yeah like this
so you will be using
these muscles yeah and another tip make
sure that no matter where your torso is
rotating your feeling is always going to
the same place in the same direction
because sometimes when we rotate the
torso there is a tendency of the free
leg to follow
what the torso is doing so that's wrong
yeah that's why it's called dissociation
because you are dissociating the free
leg from the torso so no matter what
direction your torso is looking
your leg is always going in a straight
line in the same direction to the side
okay
so
now we will do it together with the
metronome
same speed as before
yeah i will show you from the back so
you can follow
uh
with the same leg yeah now put your
weight on the left leg right leg is free
and the first time that you open your
free leg to the side you will rotate
towards the standing leg yeah this will
be the first rotation
and then
the second obviously towards the free
leg yeah so standing like three legs
standing like three legs okay let's do
it 16 times
get ready
wait on the left
and let's go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay remember to move slowly so that
your legs are always moving and you
don't have any stops and one last thing
the
the head follows the rotation of the
torso the torso and the head move
together because this dissociation
distortion is
uh
is used to follow your partner okay
we're following your partner so of
course you want to look at your partner
as well okay
so now get ready feet together and put
your weight on the
right leg yeah
remember when you open the left leg now
the first rotation will be towards your
standing leg like this okay
so let's do it 16 times
let's go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
great
so be careful with the dissociation yeah
when you are
turning your torso make sure that
nothing changes orientation apart from
the torso make sure that your the knee
of the standing leg is not moving
to its side make sure that the hip is
not moving yeah
nothing moves below this point yeah
below this point
everything is looking in front your
knees are looking front your hip is
looking front okay
good let's go to the next exercise okay
in this exercise we will repeat the
projection to the side without
dissociation from the torso yeah keeping
the torso always front but we will move
the leg faster yeah we will take only
one bit to open the free leg and one bit
to close it yeah so it will be like this
remember that as you open the free leg
you also bend the standing leg so you go
down yeah and then you stretch the
standing leg
when you close the free leg okay
and remember to adjust the speed of the
movement so that your legs are always
moving moving yeah always moving there
is no
time when the legs are stopped
okay
so because we take half the time to each
movement we will do it double amount of
time so we will do it four times eight
with each leg okay
so
let's
switch on the metronome
open
close
close yeah
so get ready
put the stick on the place that you have
chosen
to use it then put your
your weight on the left leg and we will
work with the right leg okay
let's go
ah
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight and the last one
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
great now one tip of course you should
be on your axis yeah on on the standing
legs axis when you move your free leg
but you can also do this you can also
put your axis very slightly
on the direction of the free leg yeah so
you're not exactly on top of your free
leg or a standing leg
you are a little bit
or towards the three legs so the free
leg has a little bit of weight on it
yeah
this um imitates the intention of going
so that's one thing you can do okay so
now let's do the other leg so feet
together put your weight on the right
yeah and let's work with the left
okay let's go together
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
great
let's go to the next exercise okay in
this exercise we project our free leg to
the side again fast using only one bit
to open it and one bit to close it and
we add dissociation yeah so when you
open the leg the first time you turn the
torso towards the standing leg and when
you open it the second time you turn the
torso towards the free leg okay
standing leg
freely
yeah
then remember the tips for the torsion
yeah first of all use the side muscles
of your torso to make the torsion happen
as low as possible right above
the hip yeah not
up in the shoulders really low okay and
the second tip is no matter where your
torso is going the free leg is always
moving on the same direction yeah avoid
having the free leg following the torso
that's why you call it dissociation
because you dissociate the leg from the
toes yeah so no matter what you do with
the torso you are always moving the leg
exactly in the same
line
okay
so we will do it
uh four times eight with each leg yeah
let's
start
remember that you have two options for
the stick either above your head if you
want to work more on the
muscles of the torso for your posture
or in tongue membranes if you want to
work more on the position of your arms
okay
so fit together
put your weight on the left and we will
work on the right and the first torsion
remember is towards the standing leg
okay and then towards the freeway so
let's do it four times eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven eight
okay
good
remember to keep your face and torso
moving together because you follow your
timer and remember also the tip about
putting your axis slightly towards the
free leg yeah so you have a little bit
of weight on it
yeah
okay let's do it with the other leg
now we work with the
left leg
and we put our weight on the right leg
so get ready feet together
wait on the right
and let's do it four times eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
and one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
okay
great
let's go to the next exercise okay so in
this exercise we will project our free
leg again slowly using two beads
to open it and two bits to close it
without using dissociation your torso
will be always front but this time we
will project the leg front
so i'll show you from the side now you
start with feet together
and then you put your weight on the
right leg and then you project the free
leg front
and then back yeah when you project the
you bend the standing leg and when you
close your free leg you stretch the
standing leg so you go up yeah keep the
toes of the free foot always on the
floor always on the floor yeah and keep
also the knee of the free leg straight
yeah all the time okay
it's a bit like sitting on a chair the
other the feeling of sitting on a chair
okay we do it slowly and we do it twice
eight times
with each leg
okay
so
let's do it together feet together
stick
in tango embrace
put your weight on the right leg
and then let's do it slowly twice eight
times
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
eight more
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
remember that here you can also use this
trick of moving your axis a little bit
towards your free leg so you have a
little bit of weight on this foot yeah
not completely on your axis on top of
your standing foot but a little bit
forward a little bit of weight on the
free leg yeah
okay so let's do it to the other side
so feet together
stick ready arms in position and then
put your weight on the left leg and we
work with the right and we do it
uh twice three times yeah
so let's go together
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
hey
eight more
one
two
three
four
five
six seven
eight
okay good let's go to the next one okay
in this exercise we will do the same
yeah we will project our free leg
forward
using two beats to open the leg and two
beats to close the leg and also bending
the knee of the standing leg every time
we project the leg
but we will add dissociation yeah
so when you project the free leg the
first time you turn the torso towards
the free leg like this yeah and when you
project the leg forward the second time
you turn the torso towards the standing
leg like this now this dissociation
towards the free leg
it feels easier because it's the natural
dissociation of uh
our bodies when we walk for example yeah
the torso and the legs always go in a
position
but this other dissociation towards the
standing leg feels a bit strange because
it's not the natural one
so you might ask yourself why do we do
this then well because internal you use
it yeah for example if you want to do a
figure like this yeah
lapis and
everything this figure starts with this
dissociation yeah towards the standing
leg
okay
so
that's why in tango it's always useful
to practice everything both sides yeah
left and right yeah
so we will do it
twice three times with one leg and then
we will change the leg and we will do it
twice eight times yeah remember the tips
about the dissociation so make it as low
as you can yeah make the torsion happen
right above the hip
okay so that the embrace doesn't change
at all yeah when you turn the torso move
your head with the torso as well so you
follow the partner okay and no matter
where your torso is going towards the
free leg or towards the standing leg
make sure that your finger is always
moving forward yeah
don't have your free leg open
or cl crossing understanding yeah
dissociate okay
so let's do it together
twice eight times so feet together
stick ready
arms in position and put your weight on
the on the um right leg we do it with
the right leg now yeah weight on the
right leg and we work with the left leg
okay
let's go to isolate slowly
one
two
three
four
slowly
five
six
seven
eight
eight more
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
remember to
move your axis a little bit towards the
standing leg okay
good so let's do it with the other leg
so feet together put your weight on the
left now and we work with the right leg
okay so let's do it twice eight times
[Music]
one
two
three
keep your legs always moving four
five
slowly
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
great let's go to the next exercise okay
in this exercise we will project again
our free leg forward yeah we won't use
the association that also will be
looking forward all the time but we will
do it faster we will take only one bit
to open the leg and one week to close it
yeah so we will be like
yeah remember to bend the knee of your
standing leg every time you project your
free leg yeah and to stretch it when you
close it
and also to
move your axis slightly forward so you
put a little bit of weight on the free
leg yeah and the free leg always moves
on the floor the toes are always in
contact with the floor okay remember the
feeling of sitting in a chair
okay so let's do it together
four times
eight
yeah
so get ready feet together
arms in position
and put your weight on the right leg and
we work with the left leg okay let's go
four times eight
one
two
three
four
five six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
the last one
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
good let's do the other side
so fit together
zero position and put your weight
on the left now and we work with the
right
okay four times eight let's go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three four
five
six
seven
eight and the last one
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
okay great
let's go to the next exercise okay in
this exercise we project our free leg
again forward taking only one bit to
open the leg and wanting to close it
also bending the standing leg every time
we project the neck and stretching it
when we close the leg but we will add
dissociation yeah
so when you project the free leg forward
the first time you turn the torso
towards the free leg and when you
project the leg the second time you turn
the torso towards the standing leg
okay remember the tips make your torsion
happen low above the hip
keep your head and your torso aligned
all the time because you are following
your partner
and make sure that no matter where your
torso is going your free leg is always
going forward in the same direction
don't move the leg with the toes okay
this is it
yes
so we will make it
four times eight
with the bedroom
starting with the left leg
so
put your feet together get ready
put your weight on the right leg
and let's do it together
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven eight
okay
great let's move to the other side so
sit together and put your weight
on the left now and we work with the
right four times eight let's do it
together
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
and eight
okay great let's go to the next exercise
okay in this exercise we will project
our three leg backwards yeah
and we will use two beats to open the
leg
and two beats to close it so it would be
okay
we won't use dissociation so the torso
will be always looking forward yeah and
we will also bend the standing leg every
time we project the free leg
and we will stretch the standing leg
when we close the leg yeah so it's like
this you start with both legs straight
and then you bend the standing leg on
your project
okay now a few tips for the free leg
when you project it back at the end of
the movement
stretch the foot
so that your toes are pointing down on
the floor yeah don't keep your heel
close to the floor like this no
stretch the foot
and have your heel up
and then also at the end of the movement
stretch the leg yeah stretch the leg
completely
and then relax the leg
when you want to close it
okay
good so let's do it slowly
twice in times with each leg
and let's go so
feet together
arms ready
then put your weight on the right leg
and both legs are straight okay
and then we go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
eight more one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
good now let's go to the other side
yeah here you can also
move your axis a little bit towards the
free leg when you project it yeah so
that you put a bit of weight on the foot
yeah this imitates the intention of
going back although you are still not
going back
okay
so let's go feet together put your
weight now on the
left leg and we project the right leg
okay
twice eight let's
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
anymore one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
cool
let's go to the next one okay so in this
exercise
we project our leg back yeah taking two
bits to open it and two bits to close it
so slow and we add dissociation yeah so
when you project your free leg the first
time you rotate the torso towards the
standing leg yeah this is a natural
dissociation and when you project the
leg but the second time you rotate the
torso towards the freeway yeah this
would be the anti-natural dissociation
but it's also useful for example
when you do a step back and a gaucho
yeah usually or an adornment but
especially with an angel you turn the
torso a bit towards the free leg yeah so
this is also a useful dissociation okay
so remember the tips
when you project the leg you also bend
the standing leg yeah and then you
stretch it when you close the leg when
you project the leg you stretch the foot
of the free leg so that your toes are
pointing down at the end of the movement
and also the leg is straight yeah be
careful don't roll the foot towards the
outside yeah don't let your heel fall
keep your heel up and the contact with
the big toe
okay
and then for the torsion like we said
before try to make the torsion happen as
low as possible just above the hip yeah
so that your torso moves stable
and in one unit and also keep your head
and the torso together yeah
because you are following the partner
and also don't forget
dissociate yeah so when you turn the
torso uh don't allow the free leg to
move with the torso yeah no matter what
your torso is doing
your leg has to always go in the same
direction which is back yeah and for the
same reason when you project the leg
back don't let your torso tilt forward
yeah or don't let your hip
tilt back
yeah you have to keep your core tight
you know
have a straight posture and dissociate
properly yeah and a trick that will help
you with this is um what we have done
before which is to move your axis
a little bit towards the free leg yeah
not so much that you have
too much weight on this leg and you
cannot move it but a little bit a little
bit of weight
yeah
very very small this will help you to
keep your torso straight okay
so let's uh do it together twice eight
times
with each leg
so get ready feet together arms in
position straight posture
find your balance on the right leg
yeah and let's work with the left leg
all right
let's go
one
two
three
four
keep your legs always moving yeah
five
six
seven
eight
eight more
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
good let's move to the other side
so get ready feet together
arms in position and find your balance
on your left leg and we work with the
right one okay
so let's go twice eight times
one
two
three
four
five
six
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay a useful tip for this
because the movement can be can feel a
bit abstract so if you're a man yeah you
could imagine that when you are
projecting the leg
you are actually about to bring your
partner the woman on your side as if you
wanted to do a step with her following
you going forward on your side yeah or
bring her
on the other side yeah here yeah imagine
your partner is in front of you and you
are bringing her on this side
if you are a woman
you can imagine the opposite you are
going backwards and your partner is
coming forward on this side
yeah which is very common
or it's going forward on this side
yeah
we don't do the step yet
but we already do the projection but you
can imagine this movement of your
partner to help you
understand what you're doing better okay
good let's go to the next exercise okay
in this exercise we will project our leg
backwards again
and we will take one bit to open the leg
and one bit to close the leg so it will
be fast and we will introduce
dissociation yeah so when you project
your free leg backwards the first time
you turn the torso towards the standing
leg yeah this is a natural
um
dissociation
and when you project the free leg
backwards the second time you turn the
torso towards the freeway which is a
natural dissociation but as we said
before it's useful when you do a gantry
yeah because your partner is usually on
the side of the free leg and you have to
turn the torso towards the free leg so
this would
be the same dissociation okay so let's
remember quickly all the technical
things that you have to think about when
you do the exercise
so first of all when you project the
three leg back you also bend the
standing leg yeah
and then you stretch the standing leg
when you close the free leg yeah when
you project the free leg
make sure that you
stretch the foot so that your toes are
pointing down don't let your heel fall
to the outside yeah from behind
don't let this happen yeah
keep your heel up and towards the inside
yeah and make sure that the free leg is
stretched when you finish the movement
yeah
stretching now for the rotation yeah
remember
to use your back muscles and your side
muscles so that the rotation happens as
low as possible yeah really low above
the hip
then keep your head and the torso
together when you rotate the torso
because you are following your partner
okay
then
when you rotate the torso no matter in
which direction
do a proper dissociation so don't let
your free leg follow the rotation of the
torso
because
that's wrong yeah you have to keep your
free leg going exactly in the same
direction
no matter what your torso is doing
okay
and also
for the same reason
don't tilt your torso forward when you
project the free leg back
yeah you really have to disconnect them
and
do proper dissociation okay
and that's it
the first time you project the leg back
you turn towards the standing leg and
the second time you turn towards the
freeway
okay we will do it four times eight
and we start with the left leg so get
ready feet together
find your balance on the right leg
that leg is straight and let's do it
four times eight together
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
good
let's do it to the other side now
keep your core tight all the time yeah
so your torso stays straight and if you
want you can also use the trick of
moving your axis slightly towards the
free leg so you put a bit of weight on
the foot okay just a little bit
okay let's do it now to the other side
so find your balance on the left leg
and we work with the right leg
okay four times eight together
let's go
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
[Music]
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay
good
so let's see we are done
for today yeah
i know that these exercises are
repetitive and maybe heavy it's a lot of
doing the same but remember that
we are trying to build good habits yeah
it's not about understanding things
better but it's about getting habits
into your body so that when you dance
you have the proper technique without
thinking about it yeah
and the key for that is repetition yeah
repetition repetition repetition
and by working on these basics you have
these very basic movements
mixing a few
basic elements like projection torsion
venue
of standing leg
everything else that is more advanced
will be much easier
because you are building a lot of
strength on your legs a lot of balance
yeah
and your basics are becoming very strong
so when you try other things which are
based technically on these basics they
will become much easier okay so trust
this work practice often thank you for
watching and i will see you on the next
video bye bye